here on Journey to the microcosmos we
have a complicated relationship with
worms on the one hand they are gross
they wiggle around they end up in body
parts they cause disease all those
things aren't great on the other hand
they're everywhere you cannot Escape
worms especially in the microcosmos and
given everything that we have said about
how gross worms are that doesn't sound
like good news but there's something to
be said for ubiquity absence may make
the heart grow fonder but constant worm
encounters can go a long way too we
might even have a little affection for
them at this point so today we're going
to look back on some of those many
encounters and see what it is that makes
worms so hard to ignore let's start out
though by talking about what a worm
actually even
is
[Music]
there are no ghosts in the microcosmos
there is no Halloween in the microcosmos
but if there were this flat worm would
fit in quite nicely with its spectral
appearance it might be navigating its
way through a field of other organisms
but it looks like it had three minutes
to prepare for a costume party and
decided to go with the classic old bed
sheet with eyeholes ghost costume and
maybe comparing this flat worm or even
worms in general to a ghost is kind of
Apt ghosts straddle Two Worlds and so do
worms though in their case instead of
Bridging the realm of the living and
dead worms managed to stretch between
the micro and the macro
[Music]
and Akin to ghosts worms might seem like
a sort of reduced form of life after all
for a lot of us worms are the Wiggly
tubes that we dug up from playgrounds
and of all of the worms flat worms are
perhaps the most simple Le of all but
even digging into what it means to be
the simplest worm makes the whole notion
of Simplicity seem
ludicrous so let's start with the
broader question what are worms other
than Wiggly self-mating
tubes while we generally use the word
worm to describe many different
unrelated invertebrate tubular animals
that belong to a number of different f
there are three main Fila that people
focus on the first are our flatworm
buddies here who are known more formally
as the platty
helenes then there is the philm nematoda
known less formally as round worms we've
come across nematodes many times in our
journey through the microcosmos which
makes sense given that they are one of
the most abundant animals on this planet
and last are the analita five
of our playground friend the
earthworm while earthworms are a bit
beyond the scope of the micro if you
will we've also got this little stylar
laou at the tip of its head is the
prascus an antenna likee structure that
the worm uses for feeding and as we scan
past the head you can see that the
length of the staria's body is
segmented of the three F we''ve
mentioned anelids are the most complex
they have a closed circulatory system
with tubes that transport nutrients and
oxygen throughout their body as well as
a complete digestive system that has
both a mouth to take in food and an anus
to get rid of waste if we think of worms
in general as a gut enclosed within a
body wall then that gut is a tube and
the body is a tube and you can imagine
that worms are a tube inside a tube and
what separates these different groups is
the space that separates one of those
tubes from the other complex systems
inside anals are due to what's called
AUM a tissue lined cavity that sits
between the tube of the digestive tract
and the tube of the body wall
importantly this cavity is filled with
fluid which facilitates Ates the
development of organs along with the
transport of nutrients around the body
the development of the first celum was a
very big deal because don't just
allow anals to have complex systems they
connect the seemingly simple organisms
we're talking about here to more complex
animals like us because anelids and
humans are both what is known as
seamates or use mates we are animals
that have so thank you to the
ancestor that we share with earthworms
who developed the first who allowed
more complex organisms like you to exist
nematodes on the other hand are what are
called pseudo Cates they still have a
celum like fluid filled cavity but the
cavity isn't lined with tissue like you
find in true other microscopic
pseudosym mates include gastr tric and
rotifers this pseudosym is a slight but
significant difference in nematodes when
compared to anals corresponding to a
slightly less complex body plan though
nematodes still do have a complete
digestive system the flat worms are the
simplest of all starting with the seum
flat worms don't actually have one they
are considered ayam mates that area
between the gut and body wall where
anelids and nematodes have a cavity full
of fluid is instead full of tissue this
has a few consequences for the flat Worm
but one of the biggest ones is that the
area can't support the development of
specialized systems that you see in
other animals the lack of seum imposes
limits on the flat worm's body and
lifestyle reducing both its complexity
and size but that does not mean the flat
worm lives a simple
[Music]
life of the three worm groups flat worms
are the most like a tube within another
tube except that their outer tube is
much less cylindrical the flat in
flatworm is actually an adaptation
without a circulatory system or
respiratory system the worm relies on
diffusion across its outer membrane to
supply cells with oxygen being flatter
gets the cells closer to the outside and
better positioned for diffusion and
without the ability to build a complete
digestive system like those found in
nematodes and anals flat worms have to
adjust to life without that most
underappreciated body part of all the
anus they take in food through one
opening digest it in their gut and then
spew the waist back out from that same
opening so unlike other organisms who
have separate entrances and exits for
their food the flatworm must wait to
finish digesting before it can eat again
but this is not the only way flat worms
can get rid of waste their body is lined
with a special type of cell called a
flame cell that also gets waste out of
the worm while it may not have the
Elegance of an interconnected set of
organs this system is its own form of
complexity basically every flame cell is
one single celled kidney allowing the
worm to just ooze waste from its skin
and this is just scratching the surface
of the biological intricate see flat
worms are capable of like many of their
more involved worm counterparts flat
worms can reproduce both asexually and
sexually and when reproducing sexually
they can mate with another flatworm or
even with themselves both making and
fertilizing their own eggs there's also
those flatworm species that can
regenerate a trick that our more
developed bodies are alas not capable of
even the many weird ways they move make
the word wiggle feel
[Music]
reductive our perception of Simplicity
across nature is built on comparisons
compared to us an earthworm may seem
simple put that earthworm next to a flat
worm and suddenly the earthworm
represents a gigantic biological
advancment but then put that flat worm
next to a bacteria and suddenly it
contains
multitudes it is a universe that flat
worm is a Marvel an almost unbelievable
Testament to the power of
evolution
so we started with the simplest worm of
all and if you're someone who is
skeptical that worms can be interesting
then maybe watching a simple jiggly tube
was not enough to sway you but nature
has a way of building on Simplicity
creating fascinating creatures out of
even the most basic of blueprints and
that brings us to the next worm we're
going to focus on the ones that we
affectionately Call Polka doted vacuum
worms
[Music]
we recently did an episode about
nematodes the philm of worm that
outnumbers just about every animal on
this planet now it's not the most
striking of animals but the nematode has
had a few distinguished scientific
decades thanks to its many uses in
Laboratories so as far as worms go the
nematode seems to dominate much of our
scientific understanding but worms
despite their seemingly simple bodies
are a diverse Bunch which is why we
thought for today it might be fun to
visit with a less famous worm they're
like one of those relatives that you
don't really know very much about but
every time you see them there's a new
strange story to
unpack they are the aosd a family of
freshwater worms the ones that you see
here are Invaders they showed up
uninvited in a blepharisma culture that
James our master of microscopes has been
taken care of for a long time and while
aosa worms are you know worms they are
in a different class of worm because as
we have seen before there are in fact
many ways to be a tube where nematodes
are round worms aosom are segmented
placing them in the analid film along
with earthworms and leeches aosa are
usually several millimeters in length
their body is divided into more than 10
segments that you can see scrunching up
and expanding as the worm Wiggles its
way through the
microcosmos the aosa are striking to
look at you can see their organs through
their transparent bodies and as it moves
bundles of long bristly hairs wave along
the side of its body those hairs Mark
the aosa as a specific type of analy
called a poly or bristle worm some
bristle worms are found in unusual
places like hydrothermal vents but our
aosa come from a much more mundane home
they're usually found in bodies of fresh
water where they like to crawl among the
leaves and algae that settle at the
bottom of the water and inside their
bodies are colorful gland cells though
no one is really sure what those cells
exist for or why they have their
particular colors in some species the
cells are green and others they're
yellow and sometimes as with our worms
they're red the final result is a worm
that looks a little like it ran into a
porcupine while also having caught
chickenpox while there are some aosa
species that reproduce sexually most
reproduce asexually dividing to form a
copy of itself the aosa creates its
clone at its end linking the old and new
versions of itself like a chain you can
see the new alosa here looking like it's
attached to the other's butt because
it's attached to the other's butt and
this chain can keep going as the aosa
keeps dividing adding more worms that
are connected together so that the final
length of their combined bodies
sometimes reaches around 10 mm total
that's 10 mm of clones combined to
create one giant mega worm until
eventually the chain breaks and they all
go their separate
ways so when James found these worms
invading his samples you'd think maybe
this would be an exciting find here is a
culture full of bristled polka doted
chain forming clones what could be more
exciting well as wonderful as they are
to look at these invasions are not ideal
because they are also essentially vacuum
cleaners their mouths are lined with
cyia that wave around and help the worms
suction up bits of plant and animal
debris when they're in a pond they like
to crawl across leaves and algae for
their meals but when you find them in
bottles of silate cultures you've been
loving maintaining that's when things
get a bit dicier because aosa will eat
just about anything including each
other indeed in one very dramatic scene
documented in 1901 scientists observing
the species aosa tenum described the way
these chains of worms would twist up in
each other creating a writhing Tangled
ball of worms that would stay stuck
together for long periods of time and
when the scientists pulled these balls
apart they usually found at least one
worm that had been partially eaten I'm
sure the etiquette around cannibalistic
frenzies varies but for most animals
getting eaten by another member of your
species would seem at the very least a
little rude but when you're aosa it's
not that big of a deal honestly it's not
much more than an inconvenience because
if a part of it gets eaten it can always
regenerate in one case the scientists
watching these balls of worms found that
one worm had its head eaten but in about
3 days it was able to make a new one it
would probably have taken less time to
regenerate other parts of their body had
seemed to take the aosa a bit longer
perhaps because of all the complex parts
that need to be rebuilt and the aosa can
regenerate even when it is cut into
multiple segments this superpower has
made one species called aosom verid
particularly interesting to scientists
and it's not just that they can
regenerate after all as incredible as
this ability is there are plenty of
other animals that can regenerate as
well but scientists aren't just
interested in how animals regenerate
they also want to know how those
regenerative abilities change as the
animal gets older that's a difficult
question to study because as you might
expect self-healing animals have often
pretty long lifespans so it's a
challenge to wait years or even decades
to study how their ability to regenerate
changes with the wear and tear of Aging
aosa Verity however has a lifespan of
only about 2 months which means it goes
from young to old on a manageable time
scale for scientists cycling through
experiments and that makes it a useful
organism to observe how that capacity to
rebuild itself changes as the worm ages
but as useful as regeneration is for
survival it is not the only tool the
worm relies on after all not all dangers
can easily be patched up by rebuilding B
Parts sometimes the worm has to preempt
dangerous conditions and for that it
turns to the
[Music]
cyst in nature the worms will likely
begin forming these cysts in Autumn and
the water gets cold and begins to fill
with the remains of decomposing life and
as the temperatures continue to fall the
worms begin to slow down crawling to
areas full of delicious debris for them
to stock up on and eventually the worms
begin to secrete a mucus creating a
gooey shell that then hardens into a
cyst you can see the granules of red
pigment swirling around as the worm
moves inside some of that activity might
be the peristaltic movement of its
intestines but it's also possible that
the warmth of the microscope lamp is
causing the worms to stir as well and in
their ponds when warm weather comes the
worm will get ready to emerge from its
encased hibernation using its head to
push at the hardened case of its cyst
until it manages to poke a hole through
from which it can escape it can take a
worm anywhere from 30 minutes to several
hours to make its exit and if there's a
thick coating of bacteria on the cyst it
may even take the worms several days and
from there well it is a life of suction
feeding and chain link clones and
regenerating perhaps not normal to us
but what's normal anyway especially when
you're a worm
worm now that we've seen a few worms
have you ever wondered what it would be
like to live inside of one cuz I
certainly haven't but there is a ciliate
that does like to live in the guts of
worms so in our next video we're going
to learn more about why they do
[Music]
that you've heard some worm horror
stories right we were looking some up
just for this episode and came across a
recent headline from RS Technica that
read Army of warm larvae hatch from
man's bum visibly Slither under his skin
and if that's not enough to terrify you
and make you feel very uncomfortable
there's always the stories of painful
stomach cramps or diarrhea or nausea
that eventually turns out to be caused
by some worms that have taken up
residence inside someone's intestines it
is terrifying and wild to think of
something so much smaller than us
causing so much Havoc so as we watch the
Cilia lining a worm's gut beat its own
soothing pattern wouldn't it feel like
almost a little bit of Justice if this
site wasn't so peaceful like what if
worms had to worry about their own guts
being taken over by a parasite if you
found yourself in this position seeking
some shoden Freud over a worm we have
some good news for you the worm you see
in the middle of this tank is currently
hosting this strange fellow called a
radioa James our master of microscopes
had been on the hunt for the radioa
after seeing this two radias linked
together in a chain as one divided to
make more copies of itself it had come
from the inside of one of the worms that
he'd been watching when he'd
accidentally squeezed a worm a bit too
hard under the cover slip and caused the
cyot to pop out radioa belong to a
general group of ciliates called atomes
or aomed ciliates we've talked about
ciliates a lot on our Channel which
means that if you've been watching for a
while you may have picked up on the fact
that from time to time we have said that
most Cates have an oral Groove that
opening lined with cyia that sweep
bacteria and algae and other tiny bits
of food into the organism we've seen
that oral Groove at work in ciliates
like stenters and parami functioning as
the cyot equivalent of a mouth but as we
have always said most Pilates you will
have inferred that this does not mean
all ciliates and if you are looking for
an exception to the rule azom are that
exception aomed ciliates are diverse but
they are unified by one shared feature
or rather they are unified by their lack
of one shared feature a mouth and they
do not need a mouth because they have
something even better they have
worms as toed ciliates do parasitize
animals other than worms some live
inside mollusks others inside leeches or
even in amphibians but they are most
commonly associated with the guts of
analid worms so when James found his
radioa he decided to see if he could
find more of them in the other worms
that were in his samples and that meant
that our master of microscopes had had
to become a master of worm surgery
dissecting them so that he could draw
out the ciliates living within inside
this particular aquatic worm were these
aomed ciliates from a distance they also
look like worms but as you get closer
and closer their shape becomes more
definite except for you know the massive
amounts of fluff around them a dense
cloud of cyia beating
away unfortunately there is not a lot
lot of research on this celot in fact
there isn't a lot of research on ested
Cates in general they just aren't
destructive enough or common enough to
have become either a necessary or
convenient research subject in fact it's
not even clear whether or not we should
call them parasites modern day papers
will sometimes refer to them as endos
symbiance instead because we don't know
a lot about whether estoma did ciliates
are doing much to their worm hosts back
bad or good but the worm gut does plenty
for the aomed ciliate at one point in
time the ancestors of these ciliates did
have mouths but as they found their way
into worms and specifically their guts
those oral grooves became less necessary
instead the ciliates could rely on a
form of feeding called osmotrophy where
they simply absorb nutrients from their
surroundings through osmosis instead of
taking in larger bits of food through
their mouths and breaking it down
themselves as toted ciliates could just
take advantage of the worm's digestive
system to do all of that breaking down
for them as the worms digestive enzymes
break down complex molecules into
simpler forms that can travel through
their own intestinal walls some of those
nutrients would just go to feed the
aomed pyate instead the Cates will
actually sometimes be picky about making
making sure they're in a particular spot
within their host's intestinal tract and
once they've found the right spot the
ciliates will hold themselves in place
with organel that range in shape some
use hooks others spines maybe even
suckers the flat shape of the ciliates
helps them stay pressed to the
epithelium of the intestines so while
these ciliates may not need a mouth
anymore they have found other traits
necessary to their survival ased
ciliates are found in hosts from all
sorts of environments some live in soil
some live in ponds some even live in
ocean waters and scientists are using
the general tools available now to try
and piece together how host and endos
symbiot have shaped each other and we
can see some of that intertwined story
in the cat's mouthless but the specifics
of that evolutionary change are laid out
in their DNA as are the more hidden
parts of that shared history
now we cannot know whether the worms
have any feelings about their guts being
home to another organism they likely do
not have much choice in the matter but
they also likely are not prone to
emotions like resentment in the way that
we might resent a worm parasitizing our
bodies but if they were to have feelings
on the matter we want to offer this one
last detail about aomed ciliates many of
them have their own Endo symbiance as
well bacteria that live in inside them
with perhaps their own history tangled
up with their silly at hosts story as
well now we couldn't find those bacteria
in our parasitic friends but we like the
idea that somewhere out there are these
nesting dolls of endocan an organism
that is an organism but an organism that
is also a home buried within other
homes
when we say that worms are everywhere we
mean it even in the world of science
worms are widespread with researchers
turning to the nematode chinor rabius
elegans as a model to study all sorts of
questions and in the process scientists
have written some lovely things about
the nematodes that make their work
possible so in our next video we will
pay tribute to a worm that has shaped
our world in so many ways
[Music]
when it comes to the muses of the animal
kingdom the nematode seems like an
unlikely well of inspiration there may
be poems about tigers burning bright and
Epic Fantasy Tales featuring giant Birds
but nematodes have two obvious factors
working against them achieving that kind
of mythical status first they are worms
and let's not generalize too broadly but
their simple tubular bodies are just not
what most people think of when it comes
to the beauty of the natural world
second most of them are really tiny
their length measured in millimeters
it's hard to be inspired by an animal
that is likely to escape one's notice
entirely though we should note here that
there are nematodes that can grow quite
long the largest ever discovered was
found in the placenta of a sperm whale
and it measured between 8 and 9 m in
length but even that you know seems more
likely to inspire more nightmares than
art in 1914 a scientist named Nathan
Cobb wrote The Following about nematodes
nematodes do not furnish hides horns
Tallow or wool they are not fit for food
they do not produce anything fit to eat
neither do they sing or amuse Us in any
way nor are they ornamental in fact when
they are displayed in museums the public
votes them
hideous judging from that quote cob
seems to understand the common consensus
on nematodes which is that if there is
to be a consensus it is not a positive
one but Cobb wrote this as part of a
34-page paper on nematodes titled
nematodes and their relationships which
wonderfully documents his fascination
with the worm and argu ues for their
importance to our understanding of the
world so clearly he found something
inspiring about the nematode but there
is another quote from this research
paper that you may have even heard
before it is pretty famous in nematode
circles and the quote is as
follows in short if all the matter in
the universe except the nematodes were
swept away our world would still be
dimly recognizable and if as disembodied
Spirits we could then investigate it we
should find its mountains Hills veils
rivers lakes and oceans represented by a
film of
nematodes Cobb paints a world overrun by
nematodes an image created by his own
experience with studying them but when
he wrote this he likely didn't have the
means to estimate just how many
nematodes there are in the world but by
2019 researchers had had estimated that
there are around 57 billion nematodes in
the world for every human in the world
in addition their total biomass is about
300 million tons and that's just for the
soil nematodes when you take into
consideration nematodes living in
freshwater or Marine habitats or inside
other animals the numbers can only go up
from there nematodes are considered to
be one of the most abundant animal on
Earth but the beauty of Cobb's writing
on their abundance is that he doesn't
just capture the notion of the numbers
the world he describes isn't just a mass
of worms that we've been allowed space
inside of the world he describes the one
that we live in has its forms and
Landscapes sculpted and cultivated by
worms their bodies shaped around and
inside trees and plants and animals
of course not all of those links between
nematodes and other organisms are always
so pleasant in nematodes in their
relationships Cobb mentions that he once
removed over 40,000 nematodes from the
stomach of a WABE and if that isn't
daunting enough to imagine there are
always the ancient texts that date back
thousands of years documenting
intestinal worms found in
people there are also the nematode eggs
that have been found preserved in
mummies and in fossilized poop in the
19th century scientists were able to
show that the parasite ascaris
lumbricoides which resides in the
intestines and produces eggs that are
passed on through poop Finds Its way
into people who have ingested their eggs
on contaminated food to prove this a
scientist named Giovani Batista grai
infected himself with their eggs and
then hunted for those eggs in his fees a
PE I side here this is not the first
time we have described a scientist
hunting through his own poop for
evidence of the microcosmos you can
watch our Leen hook episode for more
Tales of this
type now there are plenty of other Nemo
parasites that have their own unique
life cycles and horrifying effects some
worms are transmitted through the soil
others through insects some inflame the
limbs others trigger massive blood loss
nemat can also parasitize plants
attacking the roots or stem or flowers
sometimes destroying entire crops in the
process and so with such a destructive
path the nematode feels like an enemy
something we study only to understand
how we can fight it but Cobb asks a
simple question in his writing what
would be our conception of the insect
group as a whole if our knowledge was
largely confined these simple and
degenerate parasitic forms in the case
of insects we have enough experience
with them to know that whatever
squeamishness they Inspire they are also
integral parts of our world and likewise
most nematodes are actually free living
species it's just that the parasites
have come to dominate both our
imagination and our knowledge because of
their proximity and their consequences
to our health but those massively
abundant soil nematodes they are vital
to our world feeding on bacteria and
fungi in the process they release
nitrogen back into the soil sustaining
other organisms and plants that may use
it a healthy soil is full of these Free
Living nematodes whose presence reflect
the overall diversity of microbes around
them the information is all there it is
up to us to uncover their secrets
perhaps this is why Cobb ended nematodes
in their relationships with this Call to
Arms for the field of
nematology they offer an exceptional
field of study and probably constitute
among the last great organic group
worthy of a separate branch of
biological science comparable with
entomology
[Music]
nematology we can't speak to any claims
that the nematode is the quote last
great organic group worthy of its own
branch of study but we do feel that he
has been Vindicated by the fact that one
of the most popular model organisms used
today is a free living nematode cbtis
elegant better known as sea elegans
while the worm is found in soils all
over the world what it's perhaps best
known for is the life it lives in Labs
while scientists had described various
aspects of sea elon's life early in the
20th century it wasn't until
1965 that the scientist Sydney brener
turned to the worm as a model organism
relying on its fast life cycle small
size and capability to produce more than
a thousand eggs a
day there were those who thought that
the worm's Simplicity would render it
useless in studies of morphology and
behavior but time and technology has
turned sea elegant into molecular Muse
it has taught us about how life develops
how human diseases progress and how
cells die when Cobb wrote quote my
experience in this matter makes me very
confident in saying that professors of
biology could do far worse than to
introduce into their courses a more
careful examination of these creatures
he did not know that one day many of
those professors of biology wouldn't
just be introducing nematodes into their
courses they would be introducing them
into their
labs when Cobb died in 1932 scientists
didn't even know how genetic information
was encoded in DNA more than 50 years
later C elegon became the first
multicellular organism to have its
genome sequenced and as it continues to
teach us about our world NASA has even
sent them to space so we can learn about
how life ages outside of this planet so
maybe the Nea to is not the Muse we
expected but over the last century they
have become one nonetheless and perhaps
that is the most fitting Testament to
what a muse often actually is a
surprising source of inspiration that
seems to come from nowhere and then
permeates until you see it
[Music]
everywhere we've been on a journey in
this compilation through knowledge and a
growing appreciation for worms and it
brings us to our last video where we
went from not just being resigned to the
presence of worms but actively seeking
one out and dealing with all of the
surprising challenges along the
[Music]
way we have spent most of our journey
through the microcosmos seeking out the
organisms that are too small to see with
the human eye the bacteria the Pilates
the tardigrades and part of what makes
them so exciting is that they are so
tiny every moment we spend with one of
these organisms is a peak into something
exceptional in our experience in the
world and it is the result of how much
work James our master of microscopes has
to put into hunting down as many
microbes as he can and sometimes that
effort takes a lot of persistence take
for example the creature we are going to
to focus on today the bristle
worm this has been one of the white
whales for our channel for some time and
as you watch it you can perhaps
understand why we have been searching so
hard for it it's got the body of a pipe
cleaner with the head of a cartoon
dragon and maybe you also understand
that just because we've been waiting to
find one of these worms that doesn't
mean we are guaranteed anything after
all one of the things you have to accept
about the microcosmos and microb hunting
is that it is a big world full of tiny
creatures and it can take a while to
find some of them the fact that we are
showing you one of these brizzle worms
right now spoils The Twist we would
usually build into but surprise we found
a bristle worm the real twist is that
this was not the first bristle worm we
found this was the first bristle worm we
found 20 cm of segments and bristles
climbing up the side of a tank before
burrowing back beneath the sand
unfortunately that's just about all the
video we got of that bristle worm James
spent so much time trying to find that
bristle worm again that he started to
feel a connection to it so he decided to
give it a name it is named Gunther James
spent hours trying to catch it without
hurting the Worm but Gunther has
hundreds of appendages that can grab
onto Sand and James didn't want to
accidentally snap the worm at half with
his tweezers so instead of showing all
the features of Gunther that he wanted
to show we are going to show clips of
this bristleworm instead because it kind
of resembles Gunther except it's a lot
tinier Gunther is hopefully still
somewhere in that tank living a nice
life in the burrow it dug for itself but
it's hard to know exactly where in the
tank Gunther made its home because it
would only show activity in the dark the
moment James tried to turn the lights on
and watched the worm in motion it would
vanish again under the sand and as it
became harder and harder to find James
kept hoping that one day something would
bring another bristle worm to him and
then one day James received a package
from a coral Farm containing sediments
and other things that might contain some
interesting organisms and we talked
about some of those organisms that James
found in our last episode but in
addition to all of those James found
several species of his long sought after
bristleworm bristle worms are also known
as poyet and they're part of the
segmented worm film known as anelids the
name poly translates in Greek to many
hairs those stiff hairs are called CTI
and for most polys they are attached to
paddle-like appendages called the
parapodia that Branch off each segment
of the worm our giant friend Gunther
most likely belongs to the order unisa
but its microscopic lookalike is more
unknown to us but we can imagine that it
spends its life crawling around the sand
and feeding on algae or whatever else it
can take a bite out of you can see this
one moving its mouth in slow motion like
a weird pair of pincers inside clamping
down on something and the movement is
even more dramatic in full
speed this probably looks like a bunch
of tiny individual orange worms angled
together but it is in fact a worm
belonging to the genus cotus that can
get to around 12 CM in length and along
with its distinctive color the worm is
easy to spot in wet Sandy mud because of
those threads you see waving across your
screen some of these threads are
tentacles but others are actually gills
and in the water those threads seem to
float serenely but this effect is lost
on land in a paper from the beginning of
the 20th century titled notes on the
Ecology of seratus tentacula the author
wrote when withdrawn from the mud
seratus presents an exceeding limp and
bedraggled
[Music]
appearance this worm has a more imposing
appearance but also a funnier name it
belongs to the terab beled order but
it's known as a spaghetti worm these
tropical worms live in sand building
tubes out of gravel and Limestone to
live in their tentacles spill out from
the tube sometimes extending as far as a
meter to gather building materials and
food for the worm to reproduce spaghetti
worms will release their eggs and sperm
into the water but only at night and
sometimes even without other males or
females around they seem to do this on a
lunar cycle with a limited two we window
for those gametes to release and find
each other that seems like an
extraordinarily chancy way to reproduce
but it seems to work for this worm these
are the bristle worms we were able to
find from our Coral samples and so it
seems like our hunt for this white whale
might be over except the more we've been
reading about bristleworms the more we
wish we could find even more because
these are an animal whose existence
seems designed to inspire lists of fun
facts and bizarre trivia there are
thousands of species of poly key and
they all seem to have something
remarkable or weird about them some
spend their lives in tubes that stick up
from the sand using their parapodia to
paddle water through the burrow others
have managed to carve out lives near
hydrothermal vents some sound like they
are straight out of a horror novel
growing up to 10 ft long or dining on
the bones of decomposing animals and
some even have eyes on both ends of
their bodies so knowing that there are
all of these different species out there
how could we ever end our quest for the
bristle
worm thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the Unseen
World that surrounds us the people whose
names are on your screen right now they
are our patreon patrons thank you so
much to all of them and if you want to
become a patron you can go to
patreon.com / journey to micro if you
want to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss and why wouldn't
you check out jam and germs on Instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there is always a subscribe button
somewhere
[Music]
nearby